[Music]
david's with us in south bend indiana hi
david welcome to the ramsay show
hey dave hey george good to talk to you
guys you too what's up
so me and my wife just got married on
july 24th
and congratulations thank you thank you
so we just got back from the honeymoon
um so with the wedding gifts we have
from all our guests we got about
a little over uh four grand to uh
you know that we have our choice to
choose from
the thing is uh so my wife she's pretty
much ready
pretty much on baby step three now now
my situation is i'm still on baby step
two
and i owe about 25 grand so
you know now that we have some cash that
we need to make a decision with
um i know that she feels we've had
discussions and
i'm on speaker right now so she can hear
it too
but we've had discussions that you know
whereas in this this is even we got
married but this is more my debt i mean
it was my stupid decision that
why i still got 25 left to pay sorry
and you know i'm sorry you're wrong
your wife already wins the first
argument
when you walk down the aisle and the
preacher said and now you are one
all that bs you just spouted went away
you don't have my debt and you're dead
anymore you don't have my
anything anymore we have our your
pronouns changed you're home from the
honeymoon
and so we have a pile of debt and we
have some money
and we have an income and we are going
to develop a plan that we
are going to work together or you're
going to struggle in your marriage and
in your wealth building both data from
30 years of working on this backs up
what i'm saying david
30 years millions of families we've
worked with very few people build wealth
when
they act like they're a joint venture
instead of a marriage very few people
have a high quality relationship when
they act like they're a joint venture
instead of a marriage
yeah it sounds like uh you're both on
baby step two
as a family is that right
yes sir now we're talking okay now we
can talk numbers we've set the table
here dave
so let's let's talk about this you've
got 25k in debt she's got this emergency
fund
if you guys brought all of that down to
a thousand dollars for that baby step
one starter emergency fund how much cash
would that leave you
to throw at this debt well actually
me and her both have baby step one done
like we both have the thousand dollars
saved
okay so now we have now so now we have
two thousand dollars
yep okay and we have four thousand
dollars from the wedding
so now we have six thousand dollars am i
right yep
boom okay and then and you have twenty
five thousand dollars worth of debt
that you're bringing to the table and
she's going to bring how much to the we
she has no debt no debt well she's got
an emergency fund well i'm sorry
well she's got a mortgage got the
mortgage are y'all moving into the house
yes we we moved in together great so we
have a mortgage now good
okay good and so you really got to
practice this that's why i'm being so
dramatic about it
it took me a few years in my marriage
david and
it was disastrous i'll just tell you
it's
very very difficult and i understand
that you made the mess and you're
throwing your shoulders back and saying
i'm going to be responsible and i'll
clean up my mess
and i'm not going to ask my wife to
clean up my mess and i appreciate the
manhood of that
and i appreciate the strength that that
represents
and the response personal responsibility
that that represents
but the uh power of a couple working on
something supersedes that
and so you've got to let her in it's in
sickness and in health
so if you get the flu she gets to make
you soup
that's how it works you know in sickness
and health for richer for poorer
uh and the old wedding vows david said
unto thee
all my worldly goods i pledge right
after the
sickness and health thing right and
richer for poor and that was the final
part in the book of common prayer
and so and there's something to that
this idea we're going to leave our
parents
cleave to each other cling to each other
in desperation and work this stuff
through so how much do you guys make a
year
i make uh 55 but i do have uh child
support payments so after that
about 50 a year is what i finish out
okay and then about 52 for my wife
okay so we got a hundred thousand dollar
household income twenty five thousand
dollars in debt and six thousand dollars
in savings
and if so if you work the baby steps the
way we teach and i understand this is
all fresh and it may take you a little
while to digest
but i'm force feeding you with a fire
hose right now okay so what we teach is
one thousand dollars in the emergency
starter emergency fund so i'm taking
five grand throw it at the 20 at the 25
that leaves me 20. how fast am i going
to pay off 20 making 100
probably six months i say they could do
it less
if they go hard at this they got a team
now they could do this thing
and and you know beans and rice rice and
beans and we're going to bust this
and you're going to be completely
debt-free and then we're going to go on
start saving our
fully funded emergency fund then we're
going to start talking about working our
way all the way through the baby steps
and paying off this house or moving up
in-house or whatever it is you're going
to do there
so i think you guys are amazing i think
you're going to do great
uh and i appreciate you coming on in
front of 22 million people let me bust
your chops
but that's you know you're not the first
brother so it's uh
um and you won't be the last but what i
want to do too is i want to give you a
wedding gift
uh since we just spent your wedding
money
i didn't spend it you did when you
borrowed that 25 000. but anyway
uh so i'm gonna give you a ramsey plus
for a year which signs you up for
financial peace university for the two
of you to go through together it puts
you in the every dollar premium the
world's best budgeting app
and you'll be able to use all of this
together and george that's a great way
to get started i love it and combine
those accounts if you haven't already
i'm not sure they have
it's time good call